(cheerful music)
♪ Cocoa Crispies in the bowl
♪ Going next in the bowl
♪ Chocolate rice puffed
♪ Chocolate puffed rice
(cereal pours into bowl)
- Yes!
- Are you ready to re-up?
- Look at this lovely lady!
(water gurgles)
(exhales smoke)
- Wow.
♪ Wow
- Wait, I think
I'm going to fart.
Oh, I lost it.
- Milk!
To the rescue.
Now be careful.
We're very close to
equipment with a large jug.
- God, get your large
jugs away, dude.
- Doing a round-the-bend pour.
Yep, that's...
- Ahhh.
- And now commences the
first annual cereal war.
Who shall win? Who shall die?
- Or maybe it's just an
exchange of technology
and culture and everybody wins.
- It's a think-tank
of cereal, really.
- Okay. Let's start
this quote unquote war.
- Goin' in, cocoa.
- Yeah, me too.
Count Choco Puffs.
- Oh my God. I think
I like Cocoa the best.
I'm doing the whole
world, it's like a Epcot.
- Yeah, Epcot of cereal.
- You imagine if Disneyworld
had a whole area for cereal?
You know who would go there?
- Bevers?
- No.
- Lincoln?
- Gemma?
- Jerry Seinfeld.
- The guy from Seinfeld?
The main guy.
(cheerful music)
You know who would love this?
People who are starving.